[Music]
if you love the Hotel Transylvania
franchise as much as we do you're
probably curious to find out about its
latest monsters while unique and
hilarious
most of these monsters stemmed from
ageless fables and scary stories watch
until the end to find out where these
monsters come from and whether or not
they originate from real-life events
first time at the things don't forget to
hit that subscribe button and give this
video a big thumbs up now let's uncover
the truth behind our favorite Hotel
Transylvania 3 monsters Abraham Van
Helsing Halloween as the main antagonist
of Hotel Transylvania 3 summer vacation
Abraham Van Helsing is often seen as the
big bat and while he's known for slaying
monsters and vampires alike there's much
more to him than meets the eye this
fictional character originates from the
1987 horror novel Dracula which was
written by Bram Stoker however recent
studies proved that this fictional
character was based off of a man who
lived over 300 years ago according to
the Polish journalist Adam wachowski van
Helsing was created to mimic George
Andreas howling a Lutheran pastor from
Poland during his lifetime
howling wrote dozens of books tailored
around the supernatural he was so
obsessed with vampires that he convinced
himself that they were behind Poland's
bubonic plague Halloween is said to have
hunted and executed monsters for decades
which resulted in him being a well-known
and celebrated figure so can you see the
resemblance between these two characters
[Music]
Wayne a werewolf Wayne might be a mighty
werewolf but he's often seen acting like
a domesticated dog this stressed-out
character has a lot on his plate but
he's always got room for more sheep
while the Hotel Transylvania franchise
portrays Wayne as a reasonable guy
there's nothing simple about being a
werewolf another common term for
werewolves are lycanthropes and these
ancient characters don't mess around did
you know that werewolves are the oldest
legends known to humanity well now you
do believe it or not but there are
actually historical recordings
surrounding werewolf trials
meaning that people were once captured
and accused of being lycanthropes
the difference between Wayne and mystic
werewolves is significant especially
since he remains in his wolf form at all
times and doesn't shape-shift with the
moon the same goes for Wayne's wife and
children as they don't have the ability
to walk in a human skin weeks at a time
Count Dracula Vlad the Impaler few
monsters would complain about the way
Dracula runs his hotel and this is due
to how hilarious and genuine he is Drac
is a vampire who can shape-shift into a
bat he has long fangs a red cape and
pale skin he doesn't fit the ancient
profile of Count Dracula
The Legend of Dracula originates from
Romania and dates back for centuries
however it wasn't until Bram Stoker
weaved the tale that Count Dracula
became a worldwide sensation as
remaining history would have it I will
eat she and ruler named Vlad Dracula
lived in a castle named Transylvania
where he committed heinous crimes on his
own people this led him to gain the
nickname
Vlad the Impaler and later got him sent
to a Hungarian prison the Romanian
people believe that vampires could
freely roam through their villages twice
a year causing them to use holy water
crucifixes and garlic as protection
although Vlad the Impaler fit the
profile of a vampire his exact status
remains a mystery in the end the Dracula
we all know and love stems from Stoker's
imagination in Hotel Transylvania we
meet Jack's father Vlad who is also
based off of this ancient ruler Griffin
the Invisible Man if it weren't for
Griffin's glasses we would be unable to
acknowledge his presence luckily for us
our favorite invisible may
doesn't have 20/20 vision Griffin is a
witty character who always has something
to say but its history doesn't begin and
end in Hotel Transylvania Griffin's
character is based on the novel The
Invisible Man which was written by AG
Wells in 1897 this story tells the tale
of a scientist named Griffin who
successfully turns himself invisible
problem is he's unable to reverse the
experiment so to maintain a normal life
Griffin uses glasses and face bandages
to remain in the public's view despite
many downfalls that come with being
invisible Griffin seems to enjoy himself
by wrecking havoc on the people in his
town the Invisible Man quickly became a
scary story and was later adapted in a
horror film before finding its way into
Hotel Transylvania while there's a lot
about our favorite monsters that we
don't know who we still love them just
the same watch until the end to find out
the truth about Eunice and
Frankenstein's relationship marry the
mummy if there's one thing Hotel
Transylvania has taught us it's that
just because a person looks scary
doesn't mean that they are married the
mummy might be big might have glowing
green eyes and might be covered with
bandages from head to toe but he's a
sweetheart if we've ever seen one before
stumbling across Hotel Transylvania
Murray entertains the Pharaohs of Egypt
which is where the legend of the mummy
comes from in ancient Egyptian times the
death of a pharaoh stipulated many
things one of them being their bodies
mummification despite being a gruesome
process it did help preserve bodies for
centuries the mummy legend arose when a
team of archaeologists stumbled across
an ancient tomb and brought stories back
to the West it was then that writers and
cinematographers began toying with the
concept of cursed mummies they imagined
that mummified corpses would come back
to haunt those who disturbed their tombs
luckily for us Murray seems to be
focused on having a good time instead of
getting his revenge the Kraken it's safe
to say that every single monster in
Hotel Transylvania originates from a
legend of some sorts the Kraken is no
exception to the rule especially since
the legend of the Kraken first appeared
in the late 13th century while the
monster might have a beautiful singing
voice in Hotel Transylvania
three family vacation he is known for
being an evil and twisted sea creature
by the Norwegian people and sailors
alike these giant octopuses have been
spotted throughout history and believe
it or not one incident reports a giant
octopus attacking a sailing vessel in
Angola and pulling it beneath the sea
despite the countless rumors surrounding
the Kraken its legend isn't as
far-fetched as the monsters that came
before him the big and mighty sea beast
is featured in countless movies like in
Pirates of the Caribbean too and while
he might not be as big as some claim him
to be giant octopus do exist and can
grow to be enormous when we were first
introduced to this character in Hotel
Transylvania 3 many of us thought that
the cruise was going to be attacked
funny enough the cruise ship was
serenaded with music instead Stan the
fish man fished waiter Stan the fish man
is a minor character in Hotel
Transylvania 3 but that doesn't make him
any less important while most monsters
are scary beyond belief stan is probably
the least threatening character in the
entire film
he's a tight-lipped fish who works as a
waiter on the cruise ship and he's
terrified of wayne's pups while many of
us wouldn't think twice about Stan the
fish man he actually originates from one
of the most famous fairy tales in the
world the Brothers Grimm published
Hansel and Gretel back in 1812 and it's
in this storyline that Stan exists
although he is referred to as a fish
waiter by Hansel and Gretel his actual
name remains unknown the fish waiter
doesn't have a huge role in the fable
but he is responsible for plumping up
Hansel and Gretel with such a unique
look it's no wonder that Hotel
Transylvania creators chose to adopt him
into their movie did you recognize him
from the hints when Gretel storybook or
is this all new news to you
gremlin airline the gremlins by now we
all know that there's nothing worse than
being waited on by a gremlin this is
especially true since these beasts can't
seem to contain their excitement after a
certain amount of time since monsters
travel with gremlin airline and no one
else it's only normal for them to be
unfazed by their flight attendants
destructive personalities did you know
that the little green monsters in Hotel
Transylvania 3 actually originate from
the movie gremlins in this Ville
a teenager gets his hands on a pack of
adorable gremlins and chooses to raise
them as pets
however he forgets to obey the three
primal rules which causes them to
transform into evil little monsters
anyone who has watched the gremlins
before will instantly make the
connection between the two films so what
do we do now I think I think we do
whatever we want tinkles the hellhound
when it comes to saying no Dracula isn't
exactly an expert this has everything to
do with his soft side which seems to
take over him most of the time after the
birth of his first grandchild Denis
Dracula's backbone becomes even weaker
so when Denis starts begging for a puppy
Drac even chilli caves into his demands
but instead of buying a regular dog for
his grandson Jack decides on the biggest
puppy he has ever seen in his life
although tinkles is bigger than a
doorframe he does fit in perfectly with
the monsters so alas Mavis and Johnny
decide to let their son keep the
enormous dog regardless of tinkles good
nature the background of his character
does stem from a monstrous root after
all tinkle is considered to be a
hellhound and the last thing you want
under your roof is one of those demonic
creatures these supernatural dogs aren't
common in today's society but back in
ancient European times many stories were
written about them hellhounds were said
to have black fur red eyes and a ghostly
appearance which made them all the more
terrifying in some darker fables
it's said that humans who stare into a
hellhounds eyes for more than three
seconds will soon pass away in the end
tinkle is no ordinary dog which is why
Jack brought him home in the first place
but hey at least his eyes don't hold a
killing curse inside of them the lobby
whose monster blobby is one of the
cutest characters in Hotel Transylvania
this green piece of jell-o is good
friends with Dracula and he's known for
using his special abilities to save
people from harm knowing this we
wouldn't dare call him a monster but it
seems as though his background doesn't
share our point of view this character's
physique was borrowed from a Dungeons &
drag
character named Musa the role-playing
game categorizes Jews as an enemy who
attacks the main characters without any
remorse so all in all things aren't
looking too good for blobby
on another note blobby can also be
compared to flubber a funny green blob
belonging to the 1997 movie flubber
regardless of his history were confident
that blobby is as lovely as a monster
gets so you can believe me when I tell
you there are monsters hiding amongst
you Frankenstein and unis Bride of
Frankenstein there's no use denying it
Eunice is loud obnoxious and a little
too obsessed with her hair but despite
her strong personality traits
Frankenstein loves her with all his
heart
although Eunice's character might appear
to be one of a kind
she actually stems from Mary Shelley's
Frankenstein in this novel we read about
a human-made monster who was yearning to
find love unfortunately for him he's
unable to leave his confinement and so
he convinces his creator Victor to make
him a wife the mad scientist's plan
fails when he can't bring himself to
create another monster unfortunately
Frankenstein's anger consumes him which
results in him killing Victor's wife
Elizabeth after Victor brings her back
to life for his monster she wakes up in
a terrified state and instead of falling
in love with her newest husband she
desperately tries to get away from him
following the novel a movie called
Frankenstein's bride was released and
while its plot differed from the novel
one thing remained the same
Frankenstein's wife wanted nothing to do
with him luckily this isn't the case
with Eunice and her husband as they
genuinely appear to love each other
knowing what you know now which Hotel
Transylvania monster would you be more
scared to encounter let us know why in
the comments and that's it for our video
thanks for watching and see you next
time on the things
[Music]